Boris Johnson may have suffered a
humiliating defeat at attempts to call a
general election but here in the north
of England you could be forgiven for
thinking the campaign had already begun
do you want this government to take us
out on October the 31st or do you want
Jeremy Corbyn and the Labour Party to go
to that crucial summit in Brussels on
October the 17th Johnson's day had
started in Downing Street with a visit
from US Vice President Mike Pence and
this was the message from the White
House the United States is ready willing
and able to immediately negotiate a free
trade agreement with the UK if a
national health service is not all the
table as far as our negotiations go and
[Music]
then lights out after the remark aimed
at the Labour opposition leader there's
nothing funny about the latest
resignation though the Prime Minister's
brother Joe Johnson quitting as jr.
business minister he tweeted in recent
weeks I've been torn between family
loyalty and the national interest
it's an unresolvable tension and time
for others to take on my roles the Prime
Minister was asked about his brother's
departure Joe it doesn't agree with me
about the European Union because it's a
it's an issue that obviously divides
families and divides everybody but I
think what Joe would agree is that we
need to get on and sort this thing out
and so what next all seems set for Boris
Johnson to again seek parliamentary
approval to call an election next Monday
but does the Labour leader Jeremy Corbyn
accept that or scupper it again boxing
in Boris Johnson even more than he is
already Andrew Simmons al Jazeera
Westminster